now we're going to show you how to do
the stretch with this massage tool okay
if you notice there's different widths
you have along with here medium and a
short one right here and it's designed
for a my my hand here and I had it made
in China so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna first take this one right here and
hold that okay and she's gonna press up
underneath there and stretch back okay
she's gonna do that three times and
she's pressing in in a slightly up
she's right underneath the clavicle and
she's lifting that thing up and it's
creating a lot of space good now let's
use the bigger width okay a little bit
more outer good good right there good do
that three times okay good now let's say
for example her left shoulder was tight
or restricted or she had more tension on
the right side then what she can do is
take this and bring it out a little bit
more and then go back yeah so in other
words we can just we can really stretch
because the clavicle the collarbone goes
from here all the way to the shoulder
right here okay it's funny because I'm
at home I have one of these by my bed
side and I used to sing every single
night in fact last night my wife was
like come on give me a massage I'm like
I'm not done yet
massage so I spend like five minutes
every night with this thing right here
so we'll show you some other techniques
as well so that's how you do the
collarbone stretch with the massage tool